our view is that the privatization of
Saudi Aramco is but one leg of the
larger privatization program of vision
2030 which is meant to both diversify
the economy away from oil but also to
have the economy be led by the private
sector rather than be public sector
dominated it's not yet known how much
Saudi Aramco's going to raise in its IPO
but assuming it's around 100 billion the
total market capitalization of the
tadaryl is only 500 billion this is just
going to dwarf the index isn't it well
so so as as someone who works at the
capital market Authority which is
essentially the capital market regulator
the regulator likes to be completely
independent of decisions with respect to
the privatization we treat it purely as
a regulator and we treat government
privatization similar to any private
sector issuer so we try to avert
ourselves away from decisions with
respect to valuation choice of venue our
belief is that is a decision that is
best left to the company its owners and
it's in its advisors our belief as well
is that the legal infrastructure is
certainly ready to absorb a listing like
Saudi Aramco and we believe that it is
actually a key milestone to put the
Saudi capital market on the global
roadmap you've recently lifted
restrictions on foreign investment onto
the tatto wall has that gone we started
quite recently opening it up to foreign
investors with the qfi program we
started with phase 1 in 2015 after going
back to the market we received some
feedback and then we released version 2
what we've received in terms of feedback
has actually been quite encouraging we
then moved to the second leg of the
deregulation which is changing our
settlement cycle because a lot of the
international investors have indicated
that they wanted t plus 2 settlement as
opposed to what we went were on
currently which was t plus 0 that has
already been implemented and as of two
weeks ago we have started trading on t
plus 2 and with that we believe that
most
impediment to foreign investors
accessing the markets particularly
institutional investors have already
been removed which will allow Saudi to
become a destination for institutional
investors the number of qfi investors
have gone up by more than 50 percent in
the last few months as Saudi Arabia is
now preparing for inclusion into global
emerging market equity indices it is not
surprising that most of the most active
global emerging market asset managers
are london-based
so if anyone is looking to talk to
international investors particularly
emerging market focused investors London
is certainly a destination that they
would land in first you recently hosted
our prime minister Theresa May along
with Xavi Rolly the chief executive of
the London Stock Exchange how did that
visit go in Saudi well very very
positively our the Saudi Arabia and the
UK have always shared extremely saw
strong and powerful ties both historic
and cultural and commercial the
understanding was by the Prime Minister
and her envoi was that it would be an
opportunity particularly given the
impending brexit to free up two wards
signing or having direct engagements and
partnerships with other countries and
that was one such opportunity and the
Saudi side I think viewed it with
equally as much vigor so potentially
post brexit there could be a lot more
business between the UK and Saudi Arabia
very much so